PETER KING REPORTED TODAY AND
FOOTBALL MORNING IN AMERICA
THAT KEVIN JAMES IS GONNA
PLAY SEAN PAYTON IN A MOVIE
BASED ON THE 2012 SEASON WHEN
PAYTON WAS SUSPENDED FOR THE
BOUNTY GATE SCANDAL AND
COACHED HIS SONS YOUTH
FOOTBALL TEAM HOME TEAM IS
THE NAME OF THE THING MAN. I
EVER HEARD THE ATLANTA
FALCONS. YEAH. LOOK, YOU
GOTTA GET IF YOU'RE GONNA PUT
SEAN PAYTON'S HEAD OVER PAUL
BLART BODY. YOU GOTTA GIVE
HIM SOME SORT OF A NECK.
THAT'S DISTURBING.
OF COURSE THE SAINTS
RESPONDED THE KING OF BEATING
ATLANTA THE LONGEST-RUNNING
SHOW IN ATLANTA. WELL DONE BY
THE SOCIAL MEDIA TEAMS WITH
THE FALCONS AND THE SAINTS. I
DON'T KNOW IF THE MOVIE IS
GOING TO BE ANY GOOD OR NOT.
I DON'T SEE KEVIN JAMES
PLAYING SEAN PAYTON, UNLESS
OF THEM GAINS A LOT OF WEIGHT
OR ONE OF THEM LOSES A LOT OF
WEIGHT, BUT THAT INSPIRED OUR
FINAL SEGMENT FOR TODAY OUR
PICKS FOR ACTORS WHO COULD
PLAY NFL HEAD COACH HAS I
GUESS PAST PRESENT
WHENEVER
SHIREEN I'LL LET YOU GO FIRST.
WELL, I'M GOING TO START AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE DIDN'T HAVE
LONG ENOUGH WITH JOHN CANDY,
RIGHT? HE DIED FAR TOO EARLY
IN HIS LIFE. BUT WHAT A
TALENTED ACTOR HE WAS AND
WHAT A PERFECT JOHN MADDEN HE
WOULD HAVE MADE I WOULD HAVE
LOVED TO HAVE SEEN JOHN CANDY
PLAYED JOHN MEN SAY, I'LL SEE
YOUR JOHN CANDY IS JOHN
MADDEN AND I WILL RAISE YOU
CHRIS FARLEY AS JOHN MADDEN,
WAS FEELING VERY INTERESTING
INTERPRETATION. JOHN MADDEN.
BUT YOU KNOW, THAT'S KIND OF
THE OLD SCHOOL JOHN MADDEN IN
THE 60S WITH THE HAIR WET AND
COMBED. YEAH, THAT'S KIND OF
THE MATT FOLEY CHARACTER.
JUST DROP THE GLASSES. IT'S
THE SAME. IT'S THE SAME
ENSEMBLE JUST DON'T DIVE
THROUGH COFFEE TABLES,
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT JOHN MADDEN
ALTHOUGH MAYBE THAT'S WHAT
JOHN MADDEN DID. ALL RIGHT.
MY FIRST ONE IS SIR ANTHONY
HOPKINS IS BILL BELICHICK
BECAUSE I JUST I CAN SEE I CAN
JUST I COULD SEE HOPKINS
BELICHICK AND IT WOULDN'T BE
AND I THOUGHT OF TOMMY LEE
JONES IS BILL BELICHICK TO I
THOUGHT HE WOULD MAKE A GOOD
BILL BELICHICK. THERE SEEMED
LIKE A LOT OF GUYS OUT THERE
THAT WOULD FILL THE BILL
BELICHICK ROLE FOR SURE.
TOMMY LEE JONES FROM NO
COUNTRY FOR OLD MEN WOULD BE
A VERY VERY GOOD BILL
BELICHICK A LOT OF
SIMILARITIES THERE IN THE
STYLE AND THE ATTITUDE AND
THE DEMEANOR. WELL DONE. WHAT
ELSE DID YOU HAVE?
I'M GONNA GO MATTHEW
MCCONAUGHEY FOR SEAN MCVEIGH
BECAUSE THEY ALL BOTH HAVE
THAT PRETTY BOY LOOK, RIGHT
AND WE KNOW MCCONAUGHEY IS A
BIG SPORTS FAN. HE SUPPORTS
UNIVERSITY OF TEXAS ATHLETICS
A LOT OF CAN'T BELIEVE I'M
PICKING A LONGHORN, BUT I
THINK MATTHEW MCCONAUGHEY
LONGHORN BUT I THINK MATTHEW
MCCONAUGHEY WOULD MAKE A
GREAT JEAN MCVEIGH AND IT
WOULDN'T BE A HUGE STRETCH
MCCONAUGHEY PLAYED THE HEAD
COACH OF THE MARSHALL
THUNDERING HERD IN WE ARE
MARSHALL THE MOVIE ABOUT THE
PLANE CRASH THAT HAPPENED
NOVEMBER 15 1970 SPEAKING OF
THE 70S.
AND THIS IS ONE THAT ACTUALLY
DID HAPPEN AND I REMEMBER
THINKING THAT THIS GUY WAS A
SPITTING IMAGE FOR THE COACH
THAT HE PLAY. THIS ISN'T ONE
OF MY PICS. I JUST DOING THIS
AS AN ASIDE. YOU MAY REMEMBER
THIS SHIREEN WHEN THE TUESDAY
NIGHT MOVIES OF THE WEEK WERE
BIG SO BIG THAT THEN THEY HAD
WEDNESDAY NIGHT MOVIES OF THE
WEEK ERNEST BORGNINE PLAYED
VINCE LOMBARDI ONCE UPON A
TIME AND THEY REALLY DID LOOK
A LOT ALIKE. YEAH.
YEAH, I DO REMEMBER THAT MIKE
AND THEY
LOOK A LOT ALIKE
AND THAT WOULD BE A GOOD ONE.